(people clapping)
Hi.
Hi everybody.
Hi Drew.
I am so excited to meet you.
You're my teenage crush.
I'm psyched that I'm sitting in front of you right now.
I have loved you at first sight,
but I love your book so much.
Really, you don't understand how much that means to me.
Thank you.
And there is like all the detail is there.
You bring us in with you.
I mean, I met the part where you and Nick are
like fully dating and it's just I'm like
oh my gosh, it's so romantic.
You've lived such an extraordinary life.
I mean, it's hard to pick which facet of your life,
I get to talk to you about.
I love the Anomaly Haircare line,
and the whole campaign.
Oh, thank you.
I'm so proud of it.
It's so joyful.
So sexy, so beautiful.
I love the wet hair, the photography,
the lighting the setting.
I feel like I want to transport myself right there.
And haircare such a sort of feeling as well, right?
When you're washing your hair in the shower,
it's like especially when you have longer hair,
it's a moment.
Like it takes us time, you know,
and it like it's an experience,
and it should feel personal.
And you know, like a moment of having me time I think.
Hence the campaign being wet hair,
and not perfectly blow dried curls,
that you usually see.
That's what really spoke to me,
as I felt like I hadn't seen anything like this,
and to do something original in this world,
is no easy feat
Right
(laughter)
So congratulations.
Well said
thank you so much.
I mean, 60 million followers on Instagram,
biggest star in India,
huge here really famous has been.
It's a very big life and I'm always fascinated,
to learn how people manage their busy lives.
So would you possibly indulge me in a breakdown in a day,
in Priyanka Chopra Jonas's life?
If I may say you might know this,
obviously cause you've done this,
for quite a long time as well,
but it changes with whatever job it is, right?
So I can take you through like one day,
at the moment.
Let's go through today.
This is 24 hours,
of this moment, in Priyanka's is life.
Here we go.
(upbeat music)
(people crapping)
Okay. Let's see the first one.
Here we go.
It's 8:00 AM.
Well, I hate 8:00 AM usually
because I'm a I'm a night person.
I'm not a morning person
but I have to start with a coffee.
And I actually may or may not have an espresso machine,
in my room right across my bed.
(laughter)
So that's the first button that I press.
I get up and do the next thing that everyone does,
check Twitter and Instagram.
(laughter)
I believe that's coming up next.
Let's see the next timeline.
(laughter)
8:15.
Oh, look at that little cutie.
That's my niece Krishna.
But whenever she's around me,
she loves checking out my phone.
But you know that's where I get my news from,
Twitter, Instagram just like everyone else.
Funny story but my movie, the white tiger,
which is out on Netflix right now,
I read about the fact that it was being adapted
from the book into the movie on Twitter at a time like this.
And I got my agents to call the producers,
and offer my services and chase after the movie.
But it happened because of this.
So it's pretty useful.
I also saw that you read like time,
and national geographic, some, Michelle Obama,
you're very intelligent and you write.
The more informed you are,
the more proactive of a life you're going to have.
And--
Totally
I also do follow like baby videos and dog videos.
I was going to say, what's your guilty pleasure?
TIK TOK is fun.
I love TIK TOK.
(laughter)
For hours before I go to bed.
And suddenly it's like 4:00 AM.
And I'm like damn it.
okay, next timeline.
Okay. What are we doing?
Oh, 8:30.
Yeah. I usually do my days,
these days are starting with a workout because I'm training
for a TV show that I'm doing for Amazon called Citadel.
And this looks like Nick is getting a workout as well.
(laughter)
Well, this was one of those mistakes that I made,
where I tried to compete with Nick,
right at the beginning of me starting to work out,
was during quarantine.
And he was like, babe, come on, we'll do it.
We'll do it together.
It'll be a couples thing.
And I was like, okay, I've never done that with him before.
And we started working out and I'm competitive as hell.
So I'm trying to keep up to like the 255th squat,
or something.
And it ended like that.
Cause I was like, I could be your weight
but I can't compare to you.
This is crazy.
So then we decided not to work out together.
Just didn't work out.
I love it.
My daughter always comes in,
and gets on my back when I'm working out.
And it's like, she's like goat yoga, but with a human.
(laughter)
Okay. Next timeline.
9:30 to 11:30.
Yeah.
It's usually get to work at the moment because of the book.
There's a lot of book signing,
or there's a lot of zoom calls, interviews, meetings,
and I'm doing multiple times zones,
because the book is launching in four different territories,
which is the UK, Australia, India, US.
So Canada.
So because of that,
it start really early in the morning because,
Australia is a week at that time.
And then it goes into the UK because,
I'm in London here and then it goes into America,
and then I stay up at night.
So it's kind of insane right now.
Okay. Next timeline.
Here we go.
Noon-ish, one-ish
That's when I do brunch usually,
I try and have two meals a day,
two good meals a day.
And it keeps me feeling really energetic.
And then hopefully a nap, a try or at least like a rest.
Even if you like take a second, lie down
or read a book or just decompress with something,
I was knitting the other day.
My mom started knitting.
So I like started knitting with her.
I made a sleeve and then left it.
So I told Nick that he has a sleeve now.
(laughter)
The rest of the sweater we'll take the rest of the year.
But just something which is sort of meditation,
to me at least never doesn't necessarily always mean,
silence and meditation and the right route.
Your meditation can be whatever it is.
I think it's just resting your mind from the world
pulling you apart in different directions.
(upbeat music)